good morning everybody
the Norwegian Nobel Committee has
decided to award the Nobel Peace Prize
for 2017 to the international campaign
to abolish nuclear weapons I can the
organization is receiving the award for
its work to draw attention to the
catastrophic humanitarian consequences
of any use of nuclear weapons and for
its groundbreaking efforts to achieve a
treaty based prohibition on such weapons
we live in a world where the risk for
nuclear weapons being used is greater
than it has been for a long time some
states are modernizing their nuclear
arsenals and there is a real danger that
more countries will try to procure
nuclear weapons as exemplified by North
Korea nuclear weapons posed a constant
threat to humanity and all life on Earth
through binding international agreements
the international community has
previously adopted prohibitions against
landmines cluster munitions and
biological and chemical weapons nuclear
weapons are even more destructive but
have not yet been made the object of a
similar international legal prohibition
through its work ICANN has helped to
fill this legal gap an important
argument in the rationale for
prohibiting nuclear weapons is the
unacceptable human suffering that
nuclear weapons will cause icon is a
coalition of nongovernmental
organizations from around 100 different
countries around the globe the Coalition
has been a driving force in prevailing
upon the world's nations to pledge to
cooperate with all relevant stakeholders
in efforts to stigmatize prohibit and
eliminate nuclear weapons to date 108
states have made such a commitment known
as the humanitarian pledge furthermore
iken has been the leading civil society
actor in the endeavor to achieve a
prohibition of nuclear weapons under
international law on 7 july 2017 122 of
UN member states acceded to the treaty
on prohibition of nuclear weapons as
soon as the treaty has been ratified by
50 states the ban on nuclear weapons
will enter into force and will be
binding on the international law for all
the countries that are party to the
treaty the Norwegian Nobel Committee is
aware that an international legal
prohibition will in itself not in
eliminate a single single nuclear weapon
and that so far neither the states that
already have nuclear weapons nor their
closest allies support the nuclear
weapon ban treaty the committee wishes
to emphasize that the next step towards
attaining a world free of nuclear
weapons must involve the nuclear weapons
States
this year's peace price is therefore
also a call upon these states to
initiate serious negotiations with a
view to the gradual balanced and
carefully monitored elimination of the
almost 15,000 nuclear weapons in the
world five of the states that currently
have nuclear weapons the United States
Russia the United Kingdom France and
China have already committed to this
objective through their accession to the
treaty on the non-proliferation of
nuclear weapons of 1970 the
non-proliferation treaty will remain the
primary international legal instrument
for promoting nuclear disarmament and
preventing further spread of such
weapons
it is now 71 years since the UN General
Assembly in its very first resolution
advocated the importance of nuclear
disarmament and a nuclear-free world
with this year's award the Norwegian
Nobel Committee wishes to pay tribute to
Ikon for giving new momentum to the
efforts effort to achieve this goal the
decision to award the Nobel Peace Prize
for 2017 to the international campaign
to abolish nuclear weapons has a solid
grounding in Alfred Nobel's will the
will specifies three different criteria
for awarding the Peace Prize the
promotion of fraternity between nations
the advancement of disarmament and arms
control and the holding and promotion of
peace Congress's ICANN works vigorously
to achieve nuclear disarmament I can and
a majority of UN member-states have
contributed to fraternity between
nations by supporting the humanitarian
pledge and through its inspiring an
innovative support for the UN
negotiations on the treaty banning
nuclear weapons icon has played a major
part in bringing about what in our day
and age is equivalent to an
International Peace Congress it is the
firm conviction of the Norwegian Nobel
Committee that I can more than anyone
else has in the past year given the
effort to achieve a world without
nuclear weapons a new direction and a
new vigor thank you very much what is
your message to the government that has
not signed the ban including the
Norwegian government the message is that
this year's peace price is definitely an
encouragement to them and it is an
encouragement to continue their
obligations under the non-proliferation
treaty where they already have committed
themselves to the goal of a nuclear-free
world and then in the process a
disarmament of nuclear weapons we hope
that with this year's price we can
support the great effort that I can has
made in giving new momentum a new vigor
to the disarmament debate
the timing the most important reason why
you honor I can this year in one manner
yes of course disarmament of nuclear
weapons never go out of date I have
drawn a line back to the first UN
resolution of 1946 but I do think that
there is a popular belief among people
all over the world
that the world has become more dangerous
and that there is a tendency where where
we experience that the threat of nuclear
conflicts have come closer symbolic
price since none of the nuclear powers
are behind the bat I disagree in such a
criticism because I do believe in that
law matters laws international laws and
international obligations having our
experience had an effect as I mentioned
in this statement that ban was
definitely a part of the process when it
came to cluster mines land mines
biological and chemical weapons the
process will not be completed with a ban
entirely I can focuses on three steps to
stigmatize that is the understanding of
how devastating and dangerous these
weapons are and to prohibit and to
eliminate and to prohibit and eliminate
our related processes with different
processes the Nobel Peace Prize has been
given to numerous organizations fighting
against the nuclear forces nuclear
weapons but it doesn't seem to have any
effect I don't agree in that statement
either because when you
take a historical look it seems like
there have been moments where it's been
more engagement among nuclear States to
enter disarmament initiatives I do not
believe we are in such a moment today
and we do hope that it will have an
impact and what definitely will not have
an impact is being passive and just
accepting the state of the world the
nuclear issue has had many candidates
that's been mentioned before and I
wonder did you consider giving sharing
the price between different activist
groups or organizations or persons why
did you land on this specific campaign
you are correct in this field there are
many organizations and individuals who
are active and this year's price is a
tribute to everyone everybody working
for disarmament we have focused on Ikon
because we feel the Norwegian Nobel
Committee that they have taken a leading
role in revitalizing this process and
they have managed in admirable manner to
combine a popular engagement almost
becoming a grassroots movement and
engaging people of the world who are
actually scared of the fact that they
are supposed to be protected by atomic
weapons they have also managed to enter
the legal playing field and the
political playing field and this work
that they have achieved in bringing a
new vitality into the debate they are
outstanding and therefore have been
awarded this year's Peace Prize Reuters
are you sending weather with this prize
are you sending a message to any
particular
political leaders in the world and also
has the risk of Iranian nuclear deal
unraveling benefactor in deciding the
price thank you has yes has the risk
that Iranian nuclear deal could unravel
being a factor in your considerations
thank you thank you very much we are
sending messages in fact to all states
but also in particular to the nuclear
weapons States because it is a fact that
states are in a different situation the
majority of the states of the world who
have signed the ban treaty can do so
without an immediate consequence on
their armies and there they don't have
to disarm where of course nuclear states
are in a different position and we do
realize that it has to be a slower
process for them but the message we are
sending is to remind them of the
commitment that they have already made
that they also are obliged to work for
in nuclear-free world and by not
entering the ban treaty that will have
to be a preliminary position because we
share the final goal since corporate
there has been an American diplomatic
pressure on countries like Sweden to
prevent them from signing their I can
treatment so is this price in a way
kicking the leg yes one of your
predecessors said to the American
president Donald Trump not at all I will
underline again that this price isn't
encouraged
to all players in the field but and I
cannot see that it is a controversial
price because it is a shared goal it
will have to be a political process and
it has to be up to each individual state
when they choose to enter the treaty but
they will because the situation is such
that it is only a preliminary position -
to not enter the treaty we're not
kicking anybody's leg with this price we
are giving great encouragement and we
also want to help icon and focus on the
extremely serious problem that the world
is facing people of the world do not
want to be defended by nuclear weapons
is it the panel's opinion that the
carefully monitored elimination of
weapons by the five original States
would prevent proliferation among states
like North Korea I have problems hearing
your question can you speak up please
the carefully monitored elimination of
nuclear weapons by the five original
States would that help to prevent
proliferation among states like North
Korea I wish I could answer give a clear
answer to that question but on a general
note I would I would say that when if we
have a development where the stigma
really is strengthened as of today I
think it will affect all states in their
behavior both when it comes to
disarmament but also from refraining
actually to use nuclear weapons
if I'm not mistaken the EU
vice-president mogherini also plays a
role in Econ will there be a possibility
that she actually comes to touch the
price here in Oslo I can as an
organisation has been awarded the price
and ICANN itself has to decide who will
represent the organization at the peace
award ceremony I can has been informed
today by its executive secretary Beatriz
pin that they have received the Nobel
Peace Prize of this year and she was
delighted
thank you very much
you